yann arthus-bertrand merci d'être là
vraiment eu alors nous et nous parler du
lundi vers parce que vous êtes très
engagés en faveur du nain divers vous
allez rappeler à nos téléspectateurs ce
qu'est le lundi vers puisque en plus on
est avec le créateur d'univers et il ya
monsieur puis a créé le samedi rouge il
est vraiment contrôler lundi vers alors
déjà est-ce que lundi vers alors je
m'appelle d'abord à yann arthus ou alors
comme vous voulez un alésien il faut
savoir que la viande industrielle je
parle bien de la viande industrielle
je parle pas du paysan qui fait bien son
boulot qui travaille bien qui gagne pas
bien sa vie qui travaille 80 heures par
semaine et qu'on doit soutenir
je parle de cette viande industrielle
apporter des élevages de cochons comme
il ya en bretagne élevé avec du soja
carrie d'amérique du sud on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui on déforeste écoutez
bien ce chiffre la taille de la belgique
chaque année la taille de la belgique et
80% ce territoire va servir à faire des
céréales pour nourrir des animaux tous
les poulets qu'on mange du quotidien
tout le cochon comme enjeux quotidiens
malheureusement mais voilà il fait avec
ça et des capésiens on est de plus en
plus riches
aujourd'hui mes 7 milliards 600 millions
d'habitants quand je suis né ont été 2
milliards vous imaginez la sernam appuie
le travail qu'on a fait mais c'est
incroyable et bien mais on mange de plus
en plus de viande dans l'école et pays
de plus en plus riches et on est tous et
plus en plus riches et donc j'ai un
impact la viande c'est bon en france on
a un rapport mystique avec la viande on
a un rapport à la touche et la viande
c'est toucher la culture française mais
on peut réfléchir un petit peu à ce
qu'on peut faire et ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire
voilà je pense faut être prêt à payer
plus cher la bonne viande est l'un des
verts c'est quoi le lundi de sa seule à
beaucoup de pays on se fait en
angleterre ça se fait dans beaucoup
d'endroits c'est à dire vrai ce jour là
je mangerai pas de viande mais c'est un
choix qu'on fait les rangs on doit être
content de le faire ce n'est pas une
obligation si on ne veut pas le faire on
ne le fait pas c'est moi c'est une
demande qu'on fait est mon ami là que je
ne sais pas chez lui pour donner un coup
de main c'est un scientifique
il me disait mettre tous les rapports
que je vois des centaines de rapports
que joue en permanence on parle de
l'impact de la viande d'un jour on se
réveille et nous les scientifiques que
ça vient des scientifiques c'est pas de
cette professeur de psychologie sociale
et 500 personnes qui ont signé sont pour
l'essentiel les chercheurs c'est à dire
sur le climat sur l'environnement en
nutrition également on va juste rappeler
le rôle juste pour nos téléspectateurs
le lin diverses et on mange pas de
viande le lundi tous les poissons
ipodah sont pas exacts c'est une
perspective nouvelle effectivement qui
est accompagné d'une recherche c'est à
dire que en même temps que l'on change
au niveau national et bien des
recherches des chercheurs du cnrs et de
l'inra accompagnent le processus
donc tout le monde même ceux qui ne sont
pas intéressés par un changement sont
invités à aller sur le site remplir un
questionnaire et on va étudier flamand
ce changement au niveau national chaque
personne sera suivie pendant un an on en
verra éventuellement chaque semaine des
petits retours concernant les réponses
au questionnaire comme seul à comprendre
ces évolutions
alors vous eric naulleau vous n'êtes pas
d'accord au niveau légal
je suis pas d'accord avec le mouvement
va gagner et même alors que j'ai choisi
le changement climatique comme thème de
2018 chez même pas d'accord avec le
lundi vers le mouvement vegan pourquoi
je ne suis pas en accord avec eux on a
une démonstration tout à l'heure parce
que c'est une manière de présenter leur
combat qui est catastrophique en
utilisant soit tous comme ça extrêmement
choquant en plus ya une violence de plus
en plus qui n'est pas celle des mots
mais des actes détruire des vitrines
donc c'est pas possible
ensuite je suis en désaccord avec
l'idéologie antispécistes de mettre un
signe d'égalité entre l'homme et
l'animal suis pas d'accord je regrette
qu'à la conscience qui nous sépare je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour qu'on
considère les animaux comme des êtres
sensibles ce qui est de plus en plus le
cas ces examens n'ont pas de conscience
je pense que ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas
le même niveau de conscience que les
hommes craignent hérarchie mais les
considérer comme des êtres sensibles
auquel on ne peut pas infliger n'importe
quoi comme on voit dans les abattoirs
c'est normal alors le lundi verges et
deux problèmes j'ai un problème d'à
propos
il ya des gens qui défilent dans les
rues en ce moment en disant qu'ils ont
pas les moyens de se payer de la viande
que la viande est devenu un produit de
luxe parfois ils portent des gilets
jaunes et vous arrivez avec ses poses la
viande coûte plus je finis tu m'en a
parlé ni et à 500 people qui eux n'ont
pas ces problèmes qui disent ah ben ça
mais vous ne manquerez de 250 chercheurs
depuis peu par une trentaine d'autres
départements rôle sur les people bien
sûr pas c'est normal qu'ils peuvent pour
la lisibilité du message pour la clarté
du message je trouve sa problématique
est ensuite est quelque chose que je
trouve même contre-productif
c'est que vous laisser croire vous
laisser espérer que le salut de la
planète dépend de ce genre de
digest alors que vous le savez mieux que
personne le circus bertrand le salut de
la planète dépend d'un changement total
radical de civilisation or vous dites
aux gens peut-être qu'avec des petits
gestes comme pas de poisson ou de viande
le lundi on va s'en sortir
je pense que c'est même un message
contre productif voire dangereux l'appel
des quinze mille scientifiques du mois
de janvier quinze mille scientifiques
avec qui vous disent aujourd'hui
attention les nos accords ne sont pas
tenues on va vers une sixième extinction
mais la sixième extinction ça veut dire
quoi
c'est la mort de nos enfants et nos
petits enfants c en 2100 on parle lui de
4 à 5 degrés alors c'est vrai que la
france émet que 1% de son gaz à effet de
serre mais et alors que chacun fasse sa
part avec sa façon les plots lundi vers
cette façon de démarrer petitement bien
sûr que c'est pas suffisant bien sûr ça
va pas changer grand chose mais au moins
c'est bien pour celui qui le fait et je
pense que agir rend heureux et tous ces
petits gestes au quotidien
pas content que ça va changer voilà ça
laurent rigaud après j'ai appris je vous
laisse un peu juste vous êtes bouche et
vous qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout
ça déjà bien sûr contre le mouvement
vegan ce qu'on peut remettre cyril dans
le contexte de ce qui se passe dans la
région des hautes france plus
particulièrement sur la métropole de
lille cette année 20 attaques wegen non
mais 20 attaques vegan c'est pas oui
mais ces vins tata le sujet du lundi
vers je crois maintenant mais on est en
train de parler des dégâts oui on enfin
parler des mégane tu pu boucher
c'est un peu comme le casseur dé j'ai
les jambes ces mêmes non non c'est pas
bien très peu c'est pas les mêmes
puisqu'elle vient de lancer en direct
sur votre télé une attaque en direct
c'est ça qu'est le disais tout à l'heure
mais c'est ça le disent elle a déjà
lancé
qu'est ce qui se passe dans notre région
ils attaquent quoi les fromageries les
fromageries le lait le beurre qui vient
du paysan du coin on attaque la
fromagerie la poissonnerie la
poissonnerie ali qui est des petits
pêcheurs à boulogne à la ligne ils ont
fracassé tous les carreaux une
rôtisserie des poulets label rouge qui
court selon fracassé elle poggio c'est
c'est la réalité sous la crainte attaque
en moins d'un an 50 attaques en france
aucune interpellation
aucune sanction c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable on ne peut pas accepter ça on
peut discuter d'accord avec vous on peut
avec nous discuter il peut avoir des
améliorations sur des
j'ai ne sont pas là pour discuter ils
sont là pour dire les bouchers les
fromages et les restaurateurs tout ça on
élimine tout le monde
ils sont dans leurs modèles ils sont
dans leur modèle de nous faire
disparaître et c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible la preuve peut pas alors
j'ai créé le samedi rouge oui vous
puisque vous répondez aux lots divers
donc de de laurent beq vous répondez le
samedi rouge pourquoi c'est juste un
jour dans la semaine mais il n'a rien
confirmé
quant à ces voix là cet acte comme on
dit c'est un acte citoyen courir ça
voilà mais c'est un acte citoyen certes
mais pas bien je pense que oui désolé
merci excusez moi quand j'ai découvert
cette ce mouvement ou 7 se manifeste du
lundi verger jeu d'abord rigolé parce
que je me suis dit encore un mouvement
vegan l214 et consorts on va nous
apprendra encore manger verre et puis
j'ai rigolé une deuxième fois quand j'ai
vu la liste des signaux rigolait
beaucoup j'aime bien rire moi je suis un
bon vivant donc quand j'ai vu la liste
des signataires
ces fameux people adjani qui entre deux
avions de jet dont l'empreinte carbone
restent encore à calculer se permet de
donner des leçons le lundi la turquie
appréhendez vous le savez vous avez
d'infos j'en ai aucune idée mais je
pense qu'elle prend de passion que moi
le métro oui mais ça veut rien dire on
sait pas ça hein c'est c'est la
crédibilité de ces gens là qui passent
leur vie à en effet prendre l'avion ou
autre et le lundi viennent nous donner
des leçons mais non c'est pas des 900
c'est une crise de conscience et ce
notamment cédé le son est prise de
conseiller dans le jeu vous expliquer je
ne peux terminer s'il vous plaît merci
c'est des et rigole pas non non non des
leçons arthus-bertrand aussi qu'ils
feraient mieux de prendre un drone
plutôt qu'un hélicoptère pour se refaire
ses vidéos
mérité non mais je suis le premier à
l'avoir dit moi même c'est que cette
image vous colle tellement la peau que
quand vous soutenir le mouvement
vous n'êtes pas créateur d'un résident
et crédibiliser le nouvel hp
il a dit lu ma mission tout cela j'ai eu
la chance vous avez fini où vous comptez
mais je peux encore discuté en mai donc
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
scientifiques que l'avion d'industriels
cette viande que vous mettez en avant la
mi temps mais la planète mode industriel
est ce que vous êtes d'accord non aux
normes et veaux cochons et taux élevés
étaient élevées avec quoi ils ont mangé
quoi bein cela je sais pas c'est le
boucher qui me chiffonne c'est ça le
problème à 10 à 6,6 manche du soja
qu'arrive du brésil artisanal tout
maintenant toute la viande patent
filière tous les cochons hier non
monsieur vous ce nom les lequel pays
dans notre région ils n'ont alors là moi
je sais moi je suis d'arguin et dit pas
tous les pores dit pas tout l'effort ni
deux il nous reste en arrière et quoi on
peut pas parler et dites moi voilà ils
sont avec des pois avec eux tout ce qui
est sur la sphère n'y a pas dû y
attendait dans notre modèle économique
n'a pas dû dans nos fermes
il n'y a pas du soja qui arrive du
brésil qui arrivent mais monsieur les
élevages de cochons sont tous avec vous
savez tous très bien
vous savez les affaires dans le rêve
avec la lala bien marrer dans le
référentiel d'alimentation d'un hit
voilà bah si vous me donnez vous me
suivre et le seul des deux bords salehi
dans les hauts de france vous renseigner
sans boucher qui se fourrer j'aimerais
avoir l'avis existe l'asie nous a gâtés
ce que vous êtes contre tous pour le
mouvement vegan vous mais non mais en
fait les dégâts
à la base ce sont simplement des gens
qui ont décidé de ne plus consommer de
viande ni aucun produit issu de la
production animale
ces gens là où ils font ce qu'ils valent
s'ils veulent ils consomment ce qu'ils
valent ils mangent ce qu'ils veulent
j'ai rien contre les extrémistes vegan
en revanche bien sûr qu'on les condamne
on avait déjà fait d'ailleurs un débat
sur ce plateau sur sur les bouchers
ventes juteuses l'aja venue mais
d'omissions voilà les boucheries
m'analyser on l'a on l'a tout ce qu'on
avait autour de ce plateau par personne
ne cautionne cette violence quelle
qu'elle soit mais le mouvement vegan en
tant que tel chacun est libre de manger
non moi je suis contre toute forme de
violence parce que je considère que le
militantisme de nécessite que nous ayons
des arguments pour poser le débat et
confronter nos idées
là en l'occurrence mettons de côté ceux
qui vont attaquer les boucheries autres
parce que cela ne sont pas intéressants
il faut pas avancer le débat
a contrario n'attaquons pas le débat par
adjani par l'hélicoptère de yann
arthus-bertrand tout ça c'est allons au
fond est-ce que nous avons un problème
dans notre société avec un grand s de
consommation et de production
est-ce qu'on peut revoir nos modèles est
ce qu'à un moment donné nos ressources
sont à l'infini est ce que nos paysages
sont déconsidérés
est-ce que nous nourrissons de la
meilleure des manières ce mouvement
pourquoi j'y souscris qu'elle chanta
yann arthus bertrand pour lequel j'ai un
immense respect les documentaires et
qu'il à fait consentie z et esprit c'est
un grand monsieur
et il est là il a contribué à faire
connaître au grand public les d'exarchia
ce qu'on peut faire un coup de main il
ya certains et il nous a alertés il fait
partie du dire je n'ai pas entendu dire
si vous mangez de la viande vous êtes un
criminel n'ont jamais tenu ses propos et
dit il j'ai comme beaucoup manger de la
viande tous les jours ça n'est pas bon
manger la viande industrielle
ça n'est pas bon en revanche on manger
de la viande on peut élever le bétail de
telle manière on peut nourrir les bêtes
de telle manière parce qu'on a une vraie
problématique d'ensemble qui est celle
de la préservation de la planète de la
biodiversité et de la manière dont on va
pouvoir se nourrir convenablement et les
questions de santé publique est derrière
et de faire en sorte même si les animaux
n'ont pas de conscience la planète sans
les animaux ce n'est plus la planète
donc à un moment donné il faut que nous
arrivions à cohabiter à nous nourrir à
produire à consommer de manière beaucoup
plus intelligente beaucoup plus
raisonnable il faut un monde de réguler
ces on s'amuse pas avec ces questions là
ce qu'on veut dire par là ça ne
m'empêchera pas d'avoir vous mettiez ça
ne passera pas de se régaler en mangeant
un gros steak sur rien mais est-ce qu'on
doit manger tous les jours
lundi vers il dit pas manger plus
d'oeufs vient de toute la semaine il dit
lundi
c'est peut-être pas mal si on ne mange
pas de la viande du poisson et julien
on est en préservant les espèces fait
soyons tous conscients que le jusqu'au
boutisme le fanatisme ne sert aucune
cause mais que nous devons faire appel à
notre intelligence parce que cette
planète est en danger
pas tous loisirs pour tous les sujets ce
qu'on va passer au hashtag de l'année
dans un instant juste monsieur le
boucher
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire à tous les vegan qui vous nous
regarde soit ça sert à rien leur
mouvement ils peuvent continuer leurs
attaques de toute façon nous on
continuera on continuera à vendre de la
bonne viande on continuera le le
consommateur le citoyen il est de toute
façon avec nous je comprends même pas
leur façon de faire d'attaquer les
hérésies discuterait il pourrait faire
avancer le schmilblick là qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils cassent les
consommateurs y comprennent même pas qu
on fracasse une poissonnerie donc je
comprend enfin en gros je m'en occupe
même pas les extrémistes c'est des
voyous qu'il faut sanctionner comme des
voyous point la ligne on a pas de
discussion ils veulent nous voir
disparaître eux ils veulent seulement
nous voire disparaissent à et donc nous
voici peu mais laisse paraître c'est
bien alors sa cellule hier vers la
réalité on a besoin de qualité et on a
besoin de points qu'est ce qu'on fait
les choses bien fait dans nos filières
mais vous avez surface et jour le cas
vous pierre bouquet alicia prêt à
regarder après je voulais cette mode là
il vient pierre girard vous qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire à tous les égards
personnellement oui
pas grand chose parce que je crois que
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure on peut
pas discuter avec eux donc je n'ai pas
grand chose à leur dire s'il semble y
servent leurs produits mais c'est là
j'en ai reçu ici on dans l'hyper
violence verbale en emmenant physique le
menu des divisions des actes de violence
et bouddhistes sont bénins qui dit
babelio là on est bien sûr voilà ouais
ouais
alors alors viens vous dire que c'est
sérieux quoi pour faire avancer les
choses des bâtons des bâtons voilà vous
avez tous et je suis au chômage sont les
bienvenus et qu'elle est bien alors
pierre m'avait parlé de race en vérité
je pense quand même que lundi vers
effectivement ça peut faire réagir une
fois ce n'est pas une attaque contre les
contre la boucherie de qualité c'est
plutôt une prise de conscience de
l'impact de la viande sur
l'environnement on a multiplié par sept
la consommation de viande depuis les
années 50
alors on peut pas continuer comme ça il
ya les effets sur la santé qui sont bien
documentés par l'om ait des effets sur
l'environnement que l'on connaît que les
chercheurs qui ont signé veulent faire
connaître
et effectivement également l'industrie
aujourd'hui impose au mans de l'animal
des situations que beaucoup ici refuse
de voir donc je crois qu'il y a il y a
trois bonnes raisons
sept jeunes de changement progressif
c'est un changement qui se veut
rationnelle c'est tout vous êtes vegan
voulant la question se pose pas je vous
la pose et son constat est ce que vous
voulez connaître la maman ma pointure
des chaussures non j'ai envie de rentrer
si je veux un militant vegas
oui je travaille chez sarenza.com
citoyens médias l'avez vous offrir un
petit bokassa italien si ça vous dit
cette fois non mais je pense qu'on voit
aujourd'hui la question c'est plutôt
parce que si l'élève dégâts de la viande
vous donner l'exemple parce que on peut
discuter avec vous on peut avoir des
hawks qui disait il ya un instant qu'on
peut pas discuter la dga l'un des jeux
vous pour passer un moment faut discuter
en france les vegan qui sont il ya
effectivement des événements que vous
avez évoquées qui sont désastreux je
pense pour tout le monde
il y a près les associations qui sont
engagés comme l214 qui condamne les
violences dehors on ne peut pas partir
en bons noms ce combat on va turque sur
une radio sur une radio ils ont dit
fracassé des vitrines c'est un geste
citoyen non non non je reviendrai que
yann arthus-bertrand clôture forcément
il ya un sondage
une pétition sur internet qui s'appelle
la sphère du siècle on savait qu'à 2
millions de personnes tout entier on
estime que si on est 2 millions sans
qu'on peut on peut changer quelque chose
donc allez tous signer cette pétition
sur la sphère du siècle c'est pour
obliger l'état français l'état français
à respecter ses engagements ce
changement est une équipe on va là que
je vous donne tous rendez vous à la
fondation goodplanet dans bien d'autres
boules oms est vrai loin d'ici à partir
du mois d'avril c'est gratuit et on
ouvre une école de cuisine où on parlera
de viande comme on commande manger de la
viande circuits courts bien élevé élevé
bien l'élever coach je veux dire voilà
donc on ouvre une école de cuisine pour
parler de ça c'est la fondation
goodplanet ce sera ouvert c'est gratuit
tous les week chaleur c'est à dire merci
à yann arthus bertrand d'avoir été au
courant
vous êtes comme ici vous acceptez
toujours le dialogue
vous aimez bien les choses et c'est vrai
qu'à plein de gens qui vous tombent
parfois tuent parce que vous savez où de
mauvaises raisons
mais je d'être écolo ouais c'est d'aimer
les animaux d'aimer les armes mais c'est
aussi d'aimer les gens et moi j'aime
profondément les gens et jean-jacques
débattre avec même avec monsieur j'aime
débattre avec lui je n'ai aucune ne veut
rien contre vous voilà jeu et j'aime la
vie brian yanagi nous voir plus souvent
et il te plait la façon dont on fait la
façon dont on traite les animaux quand
on some me choque énormément csu
malheureusement si on allait tous deux
les jours dans les abattoirs voir ce qui
se passait on réfléchit la venue dans
les dix-huit mille entreprises de
boucherie artisanale et vous verrez on
ouvrira nos ports c'est ce qu'ont fait
régulièrement tous les ans et venez
discuter avec l'artisan boucher venez
discuter
venez à la fondation africaine faire un
gros débat et voilà on a échangé nos
mamans
voilà monsieur arthus bertrand et les
autres je vous invite aussi à venir voir
les élevages en france invité nous les
avons la mémoire soit juste le shérif si
vous voulez vous voilà si vous pouviez
venir moi à ma boumsong ont signé la
pétition
aller voir ce qui se passe c'est vrai
qu'on mette la pétition là s'il vous
plaît au bas de l'écran pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
merci merci à tous la ferrière